داني البس لاعب كره قدم برازيلي بيلعب في
المنتخب وفي نادي مكسيكي او خلينا نقول
انه كان بيلعب في نادي مكسيكي فاللاعب
بيعيش ازمه ممكن تكون نهايه لمسيرته
الكرويه وحتى نقطه مفصليه في حياته
والازمه مخليه اسمه في قوائم التريند حول
العالم والسبب تهم اعتداء جنسي
من ساعتها حتى ناديه فسخت تعاقد معه بسبب
هذه التحمل خلينا نبدا لكم القصه من الاول
من ثلاثه ايام صدر امر بحبس اللاعب
احتياطيا وبدون كفاله بسبب تهمه اعتداء
جنسي وجهتها ضد السيده قالت انه اغتصبها
في ملهالين في برشلونه الشكوى قدمت الشهر
الماضي واللاعب اعتقل من كم يوم
تهم الاعتداء الجنسي ما بيترتب عليها
اعتقال فوري فليش اعتقل داني البس على طول
سبب الاعتقال ويفقوا وسائل الاعلام هو
التضارب روايات ثانيه فاول ما طلعت القصه
نفاها تماما وقال مو صحيح ورجع بعدها
بتصريحات للاعلام اكد انه كان سهران مع
اصحابه في نفس المكان يومها لكن نفع
الاعتداء على البنت او انه شافها او اي
شيء وفي التحقيقات مع السلطات اعترف ان هو
يعرف البنت انه فعلا صار بينهم شيء ولكنها
تضارب الروايات هذه هي اللي وراء اعتقاله
طيب اما الين ما سمح القاضي بكفاله ففي
كذا سيناريو محتمل الاول هو الخوف من انه
يهرب بره البلد خاصه انه قادر يعملها
والثاني انه بعد ما سمع القاضي اقوال ذاني
والشهود والمدعيه ضد حسن انه مو ممكن
الافراج عنه عموما القضيه كل ما لها
بتتعقد زوجته الازياء الشهيره جوانا ساندي
اللي في بدايه الامر دعمته وتحديدا قبل
الاع قالوا ونشرت صوره لهم سووا و علقت
عليها وكتبت معا وحتى في مقابله دافعت عنه
وقالت اعرفه اعرف قديش محترم خاصه مع
النساء رجعت بعدها ونشرت مناشده للصحافه
والكاميرات انه يمشوا من امام منزلها
ويحترموا اللي بتمر فيه خاصه انه امها
توفت من اسبوع بس وقالت نصن خسرت عمودي
حياتي الوحيده وكيله اعمال وزوجه داني
السابق كمان طلعت في تصريحات ودافعت عنه
وقالت انها بتعيش كابوس من وقت الخبر وانه
داني ولا يمكن يعمل شيء مثل هذا لانه
بتعرفه من 22 سنه وتزوجته 10 سنين منه
وسائل الاعلام بتتكلم كمان انه الفتاه
اللي بتتهموه للسلطات اسمها او صورتها
بلغت امن لها فورا باللي صار انه طلبوا
الشرطه لكن لما وصلت ثاني غادر المكان
مكسيكي اللي بيلعب فيه ثاني
انه بياكد التزام وبيعدم الت مع اي تصرفات
من قبل اي فرد مهما كانت شخصيته اي هذه
التصرفات اللي بتتعارض طبعا مع روح النادي
وقيامه الازمه طالت طيب
كمانديز مدرب نادي برشلونه او اللاعب
الاسباني الشهير السابق واللي كان
زميلداني ايام ما كان بيلعبوا في برشلونه
ومدرب ولاحقا لفتره قصيره كمان هو طالته
هذه الازمه ففي مؤتمر صحفي من يومين ان
سال عن الموضوع وقال انه متفاجئ ومصدوم من
الاخبار وانه بيشعر بالاسف على ذلك الدنيا
تعاطف مع داني وانه ما جاب سيره الضحيه
ابداع الشعبي في تصريحات جديده جدا
معتداره ووضح وقال انه كلام ينفهم ما كان
واضح انه غلط انه ما جاب سيره الضحيه
بريطانيا
دكه
على على بيتي ملك
[موسيقى]